hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called Son of
the Mask spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie begins on a stormy
night in Edge City where Dr Newman is
giving a Museum tour the last part of
the tour covers history on Norse
mythology and shortly after presence a
powerful artifact known as The Mask
which was created by the god of Mischief
Loki it is said that the wearer of the
Mask will be imbued with the abilities
of Loki and become the new god of
Mischief Dr Newman also explains that
Loki was the black sheep of the Norse
mythological family and that his
constant mischievous pranks were a
source of endless embarrassment for his
father Odin after hearing all the
abysmal claims about Loki a person in
the tour group is unhappy with Dr Newman
surprisingly he turns out to be the god
of Mischief himself he soon Reveals His
Godly form and causes all the museum
visitors to run away in fear Loki then
retrieves his mask only to find out that
it is a fake piece Furious he uses his
powers to mess with Dr Newman as well as
the security guards the movie then Cuts
elsewhere to a place called Fringe city
where the real mask is found in a river
by a dog named Otis Who belongs to Tim
Avery an aspiring animator who lives
with his wife Tanya detour returning
back home from a friend's house where
they talk about potentially having a
child Tim however is reluctant to accept
Parenthood with Tanya as first he wants
to get a major promotion at work
meanwhile on a tropical island Loki is
relaxing until Odin finds and orders him
to resume the search for the mask
believing it has caused too much chaos
for mankind Loki then asks his father
for help but Odin says that he has to
take responsibility for his actions
meanwhile at work despite his animation
expertise it turns out that Tim is stuck
as the company's mascot and hasn't had a
chance to show his talent off one day
the company throws a Halloween costume
party and so Tim designs his own
werewolf costume unfortunately he later
finds out that his doggo to save his
wolf mask left with no choice Tom takes
the Loki mask that ode is found by the
river as he pulls up to the Halloween
Queen party Tim puts on the mask and
suddenly turns into a green-faced party
animal who can magically alter his
surroundings and can create anything of
his liking after entering the party
venue Tim finds it to be a boar so he
uses his Newfound powers to perform a
remix of a very popular song called
Can't Take My Eyes Off You which
invigorates the event the same night Tim
returns home after the party still
wearing the mask and has intercourse
with Tanya the next day at work it turns
out that Tim's magical performance at
the party had caught his boss Daniel
Moss's attention which inspired him for
a new cartoon So Daniel calls Tim into
his office and gives him a promotion to
move to the second floor of the building
which is specifically for animators
after work Tim rushes home to share the
great news to Tanya but to his surprise
she reveals that she is pregnant however
this is not a normal pregnancy as during
a doctor's appointment Tanya throws up
bubbles instead of vomit later during an
ultrasound the baby seems to be dancing
in the womb which is only seen by Tim
the movie then fast forwards 9 months
into the future where their new baby boy
named alve is born elsewhere Loki is
still in search of the Mask in an
antique shop where Odin possesses the
store clerk he informs Loki of the child
which is born with the powers of the
mask and asks to bring him as soon as
possible meanwhile the dog Otis is upset
because of the baby's sudden arrival as
he is no longer the center of attention
moreover his house is also moved outside
to the Garden at the same time Tim is
having a rough time at work as his boss
Daniel wants more content which he saw
from The Mask unfortunately Tim doesn't
have the mask anymore as Otis had
already taken it and kept it inside his
dog house many months later Tanya has to
go to New York City on a business trip
leaving Tim with their son alve in the
meantime Loki infiltrates The Fringe
City hospital by transforming into a bee
later he morphs into the hospital
receptionist he then uses the computer
to look up information on newborn babies
and prints out a list of their records
following this he visits each name's
address in search of the baby meanwhile
Tim desperately tries to work on his
animations at home but is continuously
disrupted by alve fed up he plants the
little boy in front of the television
and lets him watch various cartoons he
shows however further Inspire alve to
torment his father shortly after he even
begins to speak and dances in front of
Tim before causing Havoc inside the
house Tim is naturally freaked out after
seeing his newborn baby dance and talk
so he takes Alva and desperately runs
over to his neighbor Betty's house for
help however alve acts normal in front
of the neighbor causing Betty to believe
that Tim has gone crazy the same night
Otis who has been feeling neglected by
Tim digs up the mask from his doghouse
and accidentally puts it on gaining its
power he then tries to get rid of alve
so that he can be acknowledged by Tim
and Tanya again however all his attempts
are foiled by The Crafty infant in the
next scene Loki arrives at alvey's house
via the address on the list and
desperate for help Tim immediately
welcomes him inside Loki then picks the
baby up and tells him to do something
crazy but alve plays innocent and
nothing happens so thinking that it is
not the baby with powers Loki leaves the
house after knocking Tim out with one of
his pranks shortly after Tim wakes up
immediately takes alve and places him
inside the car to go to a doctor however
it turns out that Loki still hasn't left
he notices the infant using his powers
inside of the car so he starts following
them after a while Tim gets out of the
car but he is soon confronted by Loki
who demands for the mask Kim is confused
at first but finally finds out the
reason why Alva is acting strange
however terrified that a strange man is
after his son he flees the scene Loki
soon catches up to them and uses his
powers but it goes a little out of hand
as he throws a huge live grenade at Tim
and the baby luckily alve uses his
powers and conjures a shield protecting
him and his father from the Fatal
explosion Tim is proud of his son while
on the other hand Odin is ashamed of
Loki despite multiple warnings from Odin
about harming humans Loki still can't
help himself so just as Loki is about
that terrain Hell Fire Odin takes
control of Tim's body and reprimands him
of his foolish Behavior he then punishes
his son for harming Mortals and strips
him of his powers seeing that Loki is at
a serious disadvantage alve again uses
his abilities and takes Loki down
meanwhile it is revealed that Tim
actually has a very important
career-changing meeting today he enters
the meeting Hall late because of Loki
creating a bad impression but when it's
his time to speak Tim completely freezes
as he is still shocked from his previous
encounter so he eventually is fired from
his job and is carried out of the office
building however Tim isn't upset as he
finally realizes the true importance of
being a father and sees alve as more
than just a burden later that night once
both Tim and alve are asleep the
powerless Loki sneaks into the infant's
room he then casts a spell summons Odin
on the wall and Converses with him like
a video call as expected Odin proceeds
to belittle Loki but this time he
finally stands up for himself and asks
for his powers to be returned
reluctantly Odin gives Loki a last
chance to redeem himself and returns his
powers back but only for an hour
meanwhile Tim wakes up from all the
Ruckus and finds alve missing all of a
sudden Loki appears from the Shadows who
morphs into Tanya scaring Tim Loki then
proceeds to kidnap Alva and holds him
ransom for the mask and escapes
immediately afterwards Tim's wife Tanya
returns home early from her business
trip as it turns out that their neighbor
Betty had called her after noticing
Tim's weird behavior however thinking
that Tanya is actually Loki in Disguise
Tim violently attacks her but soon finds
out that it is his wife Tanya gets into
a frenzy after finding out her baby boy
alve is missing from the house while Tim
tries to explain everything after she
calms down Tim realizes that the mask is
actually with his dog Otis but he is
still jealous of being replaced with
alve so he dons the mask one more time
and goes on a dinner date with another
dog Tim and Tanya arrive at the scene
and reassure notice that he is still
part of their family and will always be
their best friend so Otis finally
forgives them and hands Tim The Mask
meanwhile in a dark alleyway Loki and
alve start to bond because of their
powers and abilities this leads to a
cowboy showdown between the two and
later they play lots of fun games
shortly after Tim and Tanya arrive with
the mask and prepare to exchange the
baby however before they can retrieve
alve Loki snatches the mask and refuses
to let the baby go after a change of
heart out of the blue Otis rushes
towards Loki and bites him near his
groin causing him to let go of the Mask
luckily Tim positions himself in the
mask lands on his face transforming him
and giving him the same Powers as Loki
scared the latter gives up on retrieving
the mask and flees with the baby in a
car while Tim conjures his own special
vehicle and chases him around town later
they end up inside a boxing arena where
Tim and Loki have a boxing match while
Tanya recuses alve Kim sends Loki flying
and tries to escape with his family but
to no avail when both Loki and Tim are
equally matched they decide to let alve
himself decide who he wants to be with
as Loki uses his powers to attract alve
towards him Tim takes the mask off and
talks to his son as his father this
makes the little boy emotional so he
eventually chooses Tim and his mother
Tanya Loki on the other hand is furious
so he tries to crush them by morphing a
giant hammer and chases them around Kim
manages to hold off the hammer for a
little bit and luckily Loki's time runs
out and he loses his powers immediately
afterwards Odin shows up before them and
reprimands Loki for always being a
failure of a son Kim however can't stand
this and intervenes imparting his
knowledge about the importance of family
and relationships onto Odin and Loki Kim
then offers up the mask and his words
seem to hit home as Loki and Odin
reconcile while returning home together
after the roller coaster of events Tim
gets inspired by a new show which his
boss Daniel Moss is very fond of hence
he is re-employed as a Cartoonist the
movie ends with the family sitting
together at home watching Tim's new show
on TV while Tanya announces that she is
pregnant again thanks for watching
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn on the
notifications so you won't miss any of
our new